i i would be absolutely crushed if i
found out my parents asked someone to be
friends with me that would yeah i wonder
if that did affect chris at all if you i
don't admit did chris even view it that
way
eventually they found out yeah
but um
at the at the time it was
they were very happy was it was the
happiest time of their life as they
stayed many many times during their high
school yeah it's almost
what's the back story behind this um so
chris had a lot of gal pals is that
correct yes in uh who are cool who are
girls but not girlfriends just friends
who are girls sonic relationships
as you as you would call it and you
would see a lot of the pictures of like
chris's earlier birthday parties would
be with these gal pals right later found
out that uh chris's dad had asked i
believe uh maybe their parents or them
to be friends with chris actually was
kind of an amazing situation where this
was
this was a later trolling attempt i
think in around
2015 or so uh chris chris themselves
tried to organize
a high school reunion so then they would
finally meet up with their with their
gal pads one more time
but during this time trolls decided to
pretend to be gal pals
and stated in their emails that that
their parents only asked them to be to
be friends with them in exchange for
like money or good grades or whatever
and then chris asked their mother is
this true and then she answered yes
they just coincidentally got it right
jeez but like
i'm thinking like because even up until
the whole trolling saga point that i
think a lot of these trolls knew already
so much information about christmas yeah
so it's like did they get it right
coincidentally or maybe there was like
some hunch being like well you know it's
also really sad watching it i was like
i attracted you to the question no no i
was just i was just saying like i wonder
if it was actually a coincidence or
maybe they had a hunch of some kind to
be like maybe the parents did actually
do this and let's just like run with the
story because it was a hint yeah it
means um
how how likely is it for these gal pals
to be so close with chris honestly
honestly right right yeah reality is
sometimes harsh unfortunately i think
one of the things that did you just
quote thanos
reality is
reality is often hard
be whatever i want it to be
i didn't i wasn't even aware because
i've never even seen the [ __ ] movie
you've seen the memes you've seen the
music i've seen the memes i don't
remember them
you know subconsciously
that that meme was really rent-free in
my head somewhere there was
the one thing that i felt very sad about
watching this uh documentary is
chris is clear
nostalgia and almost want to be back in
high school yeah
and the fact that chris never grows out
of it yeah that's what really just felt
very sad watching because you know this
has been going on we have videos of
since chris's god knows how young and
going up and um just never changes and
always wants to be back in high school
where things were simple and had
gumballs was their high school life good
probably compared to now but so they
claim right right bitcoin was great
because they had gal pals and um
yeah that's it really also i believe i
believe you know uh they used to
frequent the local game store an awful
lot as a child is that correct or is it
that one i'm not too sure about right
personally yeah um they well i mean i
feel like when you
people have a lot more patience when
you're a child
right and i felt that
chris had a lot of luxuries probably the
fact that people would probably you know
they wouldn't question a lot of things
and they would also look very patient
with some things i'd imagine that people
aren't really when you're an adult
people get kind of scared like there was
a whole
arc if you will with chris in the game
store yes
uh where chris ended up arc
there's arcs in the story there's
multiple arcs so chris you how did this
start with chris in the game store could
you try to explain this rough arc okay
chris went to a local game store where
they where they uh played games and um
bought games pokemon trading cards
pokemon train cars yeah right yeah and i
could play you know games on the tv as
well on the on the wii at that time i
believe and that's where they met their
female friends
uh which they later drew you know
right in a certain way through a rock
yeah
so yeah in this game place um
chris really liked this this female
friend and got way too touchy several
times way too many times even though she
she addressed this in emails privately
but chris continued to do so
and um eventually that relationship fell
out after the uh
the image was leaked by chris
themselves
it's like who is everything who leaked
all this information it's always crazy
it's always chris yeah
so yeah and after that point chris still
continued to go to the game store for a
little bit longer before um they started
causing way too much trouble with uh
with the manager getting very annoyed by
their constant um hogging of the of the
tv right of the games
possibly even shouting racial slurs at
the african-american children
so
every single time you want to root for
chris
just so you hear something and you're
like for [ __ ] sake yeah [ __ ] you know
i get it if like you know chris tried to
like approach the girl you know to be
like yeah want i just want to be in a
nice relationship
not in like a weird way kind of thing
and then they're just like no i'm i'm
going to do the worst thing possible to
try and move this forward remove the
relationship how to be racist towards
kids really yeah
a child
it's it's it's like a it's like a comic
book villain at times you know it's
almost
it's like a it's like a dharma video
right
it's so textbook racist or uh in some
ways where it's like you can't make this
up no one would do no one would act like
this yeah and sonya carry on carry on
the game store yeah so yeah they were
banned
and after after about nine months i
believe chris made a video on youtube
addressing the manager of the of the
game store right thinking that you know
if you if you put his name in the in the
title of the video he would just
magically see it and see this video
addressed to him well like well like the
manager's real name yeah
honestly yeah you know because people
just going onto youtube and just typing
out their full name like made a video
about me yeah
maybe it wasn't like his name in the
title at all was like the
the stock dvd like
sm q005 or whatever chris started the
video with this video is addressed to
the manager of the game store blah blah
blah and
please let me back i learned my lesson
like that i remember this yeah i do
remember this right and the manager was
like no oh yeah that
like about half a year maybe after that
chris was convinced by a troll some
gal pal or or girlfriend online to um go
back to the game store and try to get
themselves unbanned
um
they actually recorded the conversation
privately on their person of course
because because chris's girlfriend e
girlfriend at the time as far as they
knew thought it would be a very good
idea and like they would like be able to
uh
threaten the manager with like oh oh you
said this and i don't know
right yeah use used his blackmail tried
to blackmail that right right and then
the manager said no and just kicked him
out again and i think threatened to call
the police and then on the way out chris
called the manager a jew
and um
you know what i mean you see what i mean
okay that happened right yeah that
happened and then
other things happened yes about another
year after that
chris um
chris went back to the store with with
their mother actually and um this was
after after their elderly father had
died already right so they went back to
the store because they saw a new banner
up on the store saying under under new
management or under a new owner and they
realized that the manager of the store
now became the owner of the store and
became angry again they were kicked out
and on the way out uh the manager of the
store was run over by chris's car
twice
see the thing was not not accidentally
right like well the thing was
we're not really sure
what was the order of the situation but
both chris's mother and chris themselves
were driving the car and each took a
turn to run over the game
pretty horrible well this sounds like a
[ __ ] loot
you can't make this up it actually
sounds like a looney tunes
so i'm not sure who did it first like
did chris accidentally do it and then
swap oh your turn
this is your police mother
or
maybe they thought that like the second
time the other person driving was like
uh cover for them you know like right
right you take the point driving it was
me so then let's run over them twice
there but anyway yeah they were both
charged with uh manslaughter no it
wasn't manslaughter no no it wasn't a
math thought it was like greed was
barely harmed i don't
um the the owner was okay actually and
he actually
wanted the the charges to be dropped or
at least listened damn oh yeah what a
nice manager after someone ran me over
so we got racism homophobia hit and run
like is this person just speed running
hate crimes now yeah
there's more there'll be more she's
trying to like a hundred percent hate
crimes
like getting the xbox achievements it's
like a bingo list of crimes it is
shocking how many you can accidentally
commit when you're not really aware of
the original gamer
the completionist
oh god i mean
i mean some people might say that chris
might be the the first let's player in a
way
yeah cause chris chris did videos of
chris chris little big planet chris made
a video on little big planet back in
2002 or three wow and they were
narrating their actions over it which
makes like that's a lesson like one of
the first let's plays ever yeah holy
[ __ ] and and the uh and that review was
actually published in the the nintendo
game magazine or the
nintendo power wasn't it
yeah it was published wow actually
actually chris had two things published
in nintendo power
over the course of their life it's like
an animal crossing video if i remember
correctly it was animal crossing yeah
yeah it was yeah
wow and they were talking about what
they were doing and uh one of the first
things that chris did during their
narration in that video was saying that
they were a high-functioning autistic
virgin
this is something that chris often
mentioned
very often because i'm a
high-functioning autistic virgin
which you know when you watch it it's
like what yeah you're actually not used
to hearing that's like four words i
didn't think i would hear them next to
each other or someone's self-proclaimed
yeah right which is just it's it's not
and the whole like i said there's arcs
right there's just and the game store is
over like 10 years i don't know it's
quite a long time if i remember about
five years ago it's quite a long time
storage and also watching these uh this
documentary it's kind of because it's
all in chronological order
it's it's concerning how often stuff
gets revisited and chris tries again